[Musica]
benvenuti zahida sarà s
oggi il nuovo video e oggi proveremo i
trucchetti più assurdi di 123 gol dietro
alla fine del video fateci sapere qual è
il trucchetto che vi è piaciuto più di
tutti i giorni ei commenti quindi
guardate il video fino alla fine e
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere altri video in cui proviamo i
trucchetti oggi scherzi di 123 godi
through through modified minex kraft per
questo video raggiunge i 30 mila mi
piace fare un altro video troviamo i
trucchetti fogli scherzi mettetevi
comodi prende dei pop corn e iniziamo
subito con il primo trucchetto primo
trucchetto eyeliner fai da te per il
primo trucchetto ho preso una gomma da
cancellare e l'ho tagliata come nel
video con una forbicina fino a creare
questa forma una sorta di triangolino un
po allungato
dopodiché ho passato sopra lai liner ma
invece di usare un cotton fioc con la
colla l'ho semplicemente infilzato con
una matita poi appoggiato la gomma
eyeliner sull'occhio tipo una sorta di
stampino però non era molto intenso il
colore e non era molto dritta la linea
dell'eyeliner e quindi l'ho
semplicemente appoggiato più volte poi
nell'altro occhio ho provato a
strisciare la gomma e devo dire che è
uscito bene nell'altro occhio però i
tuoi occhi non erano molto simmetrici
quindi sistemati un pochettino io
manualmente con l'aj liner e devo dire
che in genere io sono negata a fare lay
line r perfettamente simmetrico però
questo metodo mi ha aiutato a renderlo
un pochino più simmetrico secondo
trucchetto decorazione ma chi te fai da
te
per questo trucchetto basta una
bacinella d'acqua e dello smalto io
avevo già messo dei glitter dentro il
problema che avevo solo un colore di
smalto
quindi ho aggiunto vari glitter colorati
per dargli un pochino più di colore poi
basta immergere la matita che si vuole
decorare però è uscito un po un disastro
con lo smalto quindi ho deciso di
provare con la colla
devo dire che con la co all'esito molte
più carina ho provato anche con la colla
che si illumina al buio è questa è la
seconda a matita che ho de corato
però bisogna lasciarle asciugare per un
bel po di ore infatti alla fine del
video vedrete il risultato una volta
asciutte terzo trucchetto
questo trucchetto è semplicissimo basta
mettere un elastico per capelli
dietro alla cover e poi richiudere la
cover del telefono io ho provato prima
con questo elastico però era troppo
spesso e
la cover non si richiudeva nel telefono
quindi ho deciso di provare con
quest'altro elastico che è molto più
morbido e sottile e devo dire che è
anche molto carino nel telefono questo
trucchetto funziona benissimo
assicuratevi di fissare bene le lattico
dentro alla cover altrimenti potrebbe
cadervi il telefono però per me questo
trucchetto e approvato e mi piace un
sacco anche esteticamente questo
elastico nel telefono guardo trucchetto
disegni in movimento per questo
trucchetto basta utilizzare dei
pennarelli indelebili io avevo solo
questi dorato e argentato
nel video utilizzano un piatto ma io non
volevo rovinare un piatto casomai non
funzionasse quindi ho fatto i miei
disegni su un contenitore di plastica
poi basta aspettare che sia quasi
asciutto così dicono nel video emettere
dell'acqua sopra e il disegno dovrebbe
staccarsi muoversi appunto purtroppo non
ha funzionato in questo contenitore ho
pensato che forse poteva essere il fatto
che il contenitore
era appunto di plastica quindi ho deciso
di provare sul retro di un piatto di
ceramica
ho aspettato che i disegni fossero quasi
asciutti e versato l'acqua però
purtroppo non è successo niente
ho anche provato a fare altri disegni
aspettare un po di più e un po di meno
ma purtroppo non ha funzionato questo
trucchetto non so se sia perché magari i
pennarelli che utilizzato non erano
quelli giusti fatemi sapere nei commenti
se voi avete provato e ha funzionato che
cosa avete fatto
quinta trucchetto foto con i fiori per
fare questa foto abbiamo prima dovuto
rubare il posto a merlino e che sta
sempre a dormire sul letto infatti
vedete che qua il letto era occupato da
lui abbiamo preso dei fiori finti rosa
poi basta stray arti nel letto equa
berlino cercava di mangiare i fiori
finti potete vedere poi vitale ha
sistemato la composizione dei fiori e
dei capelli
potete anche fare da soli la foto o
farla fare dai vostri amici e se volete
vedere il risultato finale andate a
seguirmi strizziamo stai ancora non mi
seguite ho pubblicato la foto su
instagram sesto trucchetto rimuovere una
spina è mai successo di pungervi con una
spina scrivetelo nei commenti
comunque non capisco bene questo
trucchetto perché non si possa tirare la
spina direttamente con le mani o con una
pinzetta o qualcosa del genere ma
comunque stiamo testando dei trucchetti
quindi testiamo anche questo abbiamo
preso un bicchierino di vetro poi messo
la fiamma dentro e subito appoggiato
sulla mano con la spina la prima volta
non ha funzionato e infatti non ha
tirato via la spina però un pochino si è
mossa come potete vedere quindi abbiamo
riprovato una seconda volta e ha
realmente tolto la spina quindi questo
trucchetto funziona
ed ecco qua le matite assurde cosa ne
pensate quale vi piace di più delle due
ma ora vediamo come si illumina al buio
ecco qua la matita in cui ho utilizzato
la colla che si illumina al buio scusate
ma al buio non si vede molto bene
comunque se volete provare questo
trucchetto vi consiglio di utilizzare la
colla direttamente sulle matite senza
bisogno di immergerle nell'acqua
le tesi nei commenti quale trucchetto vi
è piaciuto più di tutti a me quello che
è piaciuto più di tutti è quello del
cellulare con l'elastico e super carino
lasciate un bel mi piace ricordatevi di
seguirmi su instagram su tik tok e ora
vi lascio con quattro case linee su cui
cliccare qui parlano gli altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao
[Musica]